[Music]
man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well we go from one new york's uh new
york times bestseller to another one
stephen dubner's with it he is the one
of two authors of freakonomics
how did this get to be
on some bestseller list for over a year
i thought you were going to ask how it
got to be published in the first place
um
uh it's a bit of a mystery to us frankly
i mean it's a book
that's nominally about economics to some
degree although it's meant to be a fun
and enlightening book
and
and it's also a book that doesn't really
have a theme it's not about you know
any particular global crisis it's not
about any particular problem that we're
trying to solve it's really using um the
tools of economics which are these
wonderful tools that are really um great
at answering questions about human
behavior and yet are usually the tools
of economics are usually applied to
subjects that are very important but
less interesting to many of us than
human behavior so the economy and
inflation and the stock market so what
we do i co-authored the book with steve
levitt who's a a wonderful and very
creative economist at the university of
chicago
and he's done a lot of research and
together we
decided to tell stories using economics
to explore the kind of subjects that we
want to read and write about so about
parenting about cheating corruption
crime uh whether the name you give your
child has any effect on on their outcome
and again using these tools that are
very powerful and uh intuitive in a way
to get answers that a lot of people
ended up wanting to to know about well
we wanted to have you here while we're
here at bea so that we could let our
viewers talk to you so we're going to
give put the numbers up right away
here's how you do it
202-585-3885 for democrats 3886 for
republicans in
eight eight 202-585-3887 for others can
i can i ask you a naive question i was
watching in my hotel before i came over
why the different numbers for dems
republicans and others just so we get a
lot of different thoughts and opinions
but why need why different numbers why
different phone numbers that's what i
i was just curious as to okay very good
glad to know the methodology i know
there's some methodologies interesting
to me okay yeah one of the things one
isn't a toll number and the other is
free no no no they're all they're all
they're all the same they're all tall
you talk so much about the issue about
the fact that every so much of what we
know in conventional wisdom is wrong
how what kind of examples do you give
well
there are various i mean
i'll give a very simple example in the
book we ask the question which is more
dangerous if you're a parent with young
children which is more dangerous a gun
or a swimming pool in other words if you
have a choice about sending your child
to play at a friend's house and that
friend has the friend's parents have
guns in the house or a gun and another
friend
who has a swimming pool in the backyard
i think most parents would typically
think oh gosh watch the gun okay as it
turns out many more children young
children die each year in backyard
swimming pool accidents than die by
gunfire okay so then you begin to ask
well plus which there are probably 200
million guns in this country and many
many many many fewer swimming pools than
that so the incidence is much higher so
you have to ask yourself how do various
conventional wisdoms get formed and they
get formed by people like you and me i
write for the new york times magazine
and the media we we try our very best to
give across information that is as true
and accurate and kind of holistic true
in the big sense as we can and yet a lot
of conventional wisdom is formed because
various experts will whisper into your
ear or my ear and tell us a story that
is true on one level but it's very hard
for journalism to present the entire
truth um globally and so what we try to
do is forget about how you feel about an
issue and an issue i would include
whether it's politics or religion or a
crime or a swimming pool versus a gun
forget about how you feel about it and
forget about what your emotions or
opinions or particularly anecdotes say
and look at the numbers and that's what
we do is we just walk up to an issue
forget about what you think you know
look at the data analyze the data as
rigorously and as kind of truthfully as
you can and then tell the stories based
on that how do you know the data is
correct well that's where it's great for
me as a journalist to be working with a
world-class economist who i mean an
economist
most people don't realize this what
economists do i would argue probably
better than anyone in the world is work
with data they are empirical researchers
in other words
they will work very hard to get a hold
of a data set or sometimes create a data
set and then measure it and that's where
the tools of
economics are really valuable and
statistically they're sophisticated i
mean a lot of people don't like
economics because it's become overly
mathematical in these last 50 or 80
years
that's true and i don't like that either
the good news is that the math is very
useful in figuring out what the data
really have to say and the better news
is that economics long ago when it was
founded by adam smith back in scotland
centuries ago
smith was a moral philosopher he was not
trying to figure out pricing strategy or
where a stock market was going he was
trying to figure out how when changes
happen in the world through
industrialization in that case how is
human behavior affected and that's what
we try to do is we try to use data to
look at human behavior and to kind of
measure the difference between what
people think or what they say they're
going to do in a case and what they
actually do here's a piece of data i bet
you know how many books have you sold
we're about a million and a half in this
country and how does that compare with
what a normal non-fiction book might do
oh uh gosh i don't know what normal is
but it's a lot i mean it's it's it's
absurd it's absurd on one level i mean
there's also in sociology there's a
thing called the matthew effect which
comes from the new testament
matthew uh the the idea being that the
rich get rich and the poor get poor the
rich get richer the poor get poor and
what you see with a best seller and you
see this in our culture in general it is
kind of a blockbuster culture people
gravitate to the things that are doing
well and then they push them more and
make them do even better it it's not
fair uh
it's a it's lucky is what it is honestly
so i've never been the beneficiary of
this big of a piece of luck i enjoy it
but it also it's a little bit odd
frankly to to witness it first call for
you is from fresno california hello good
afternoon
that's good afternoon i'm trying to
complement mr governor's book and
economics i enjoyed it very much and
also love c-span and your coverage
i had a kind of a two-prong question um
how i'm wondering mr governor how you
and your co-authors arrived on the
chapter uh regarding stetson kennedy and
the ku klux klan
and including that and then if you can
if you can touch on the recent
controversy in your editorial in the new
york times about new information that
led you to
believe that he didn't infiltrate the
clan and i know
that's sort of a two-prong question but
i appreciate it i'll hang up and listen
to the answer thanks sure thank you okay
so that's a great question it's um it's
a little bit of a complicated story so
i'll try to tell it as briefly and as
kind of succinctly as i can we have a
chapter in the book called uh what do a
group of real estate agents have in
common with the ku klux klan
and the the answer is that both of them
real estate agents and the clan back in
the day especially dealt with what
economists call information asymmetry i
didn't say it was pretty language but
this is the language that we use and
what an information asymmetry is is very
basically it's when there are two
parties in a transaction or more than
two and one usually a seller has a lot
more information about what's being sold
than the buyer there's an
unbalanced uh information situation
there and uh in the case of real estate
agents we write about that how real
estate agents have an information
advantage that they'll often exploit um
to their good and the ku klux klan we
wrote a story about this amazing um
infiltration of the clan back in the
1940s by a man named stetson kennedy who
went undercover
uh supposedly joined the ku klux klan
and got all this information this was a
years-long effort on his behalf he was a
civil rights activist long ago
he gathered all this information about
the klan and then used that information
that he'd gleaned secretly and
disseminated it over the airwaves this
was in the heyday of radio so he would
give information to the superman radio
hour and to drew pearson a big political
commentator of the day and they
disseminated the information about the
clan and when the secret information
became public it did two things it made
it much less powerful and it made it uh
it made the clan kind of infantilized
because they were this secret society so
we wrote about this story in our book we
had interviewed stetson kennedy who's
now i think 89 years old lives in
florida he'd written a number of books
many articles over the years and been
lauded as really a hero for among many
other things having infiltrated the clan
after our book was published it came to
our attention that there were archives
around the country that had information
about stetson kennedy's work
which uh which implied that he had not
personally done as much of the
infiltration as he had represented in
his own book and as he had told us in
interviews and as we therefore had
written about in freakonomics so we
wrote an article in the new york times
magazine where we have a regular free
economics column and we wrote about the
fact that we had been
misled or misinformed and and
particularly that stetson kennedy
according to all the documents that we
were then able to gather after the book
had exaggerated his role in personally
gathering this information infiltrating
the clan so in order to correct the
record and try to give his complete a
record of that history as possible what
we did is we wrote that new york times
column we put a lot of the information
on our website freakonomics.com and now
we're revising the chapter in free
economics we're publishing in the fall
an expanded and revised edition with new
material and some revisions and the
major revision will be the stetson
kennedy chapter the revision hardback
paperback it's it's still in hardback um
i mean this is a publishing decision
it's still a bestseller in hardback and
so they're choosing to keep it in in
hardback for a while i mean the good
news for buyers is that with discounting
at a lot of a lot of places uh hardbacks
these days are oddly enough not that
much more expensive than trade
paperbacks used to be which i think is
one reason why you see a lot more
hardcovers stay in print as hardcover is
longer charlotte north carolina go ahead
oh yes mr w yes
how are you um
i heard your first question about the
numbers i always had that question also
i still didn't quite get an answer to
the to the question i'm still confused
about those three different numbers but
the main reason i called is because uh
it ties into the previous uh person who
the
pleasant lady was interviewing i'm sorry
i don't remember your name offhand
uh lynn
no it's connie yes i was wondering uh in
your opinion from your writing your book
in this and the research you uh had to
have done
uh how is white americans
uh viewpoint those with power
how does that
influence
their viewpoint of black americans
in terms of the pigmentation of the
black american
and the philosophy or the philosophy
that the black american may have in
terms of their uh view on economics in
general and in terms of of whether or
not uh the door to economic power uh is
open to them thanks jordan
i'll hang up and listen to your answer
okay thank you uh that's a fantastic
question and a really hard question so
let me answer the the first easier
question first briefly from what i
understand from what connie told me if
you have three separate numbers and
you're c-span and you're picking
from group a then group b then group c
you're going to have a steady rotation
of different political affiliations
which i think is a pretty great idea as
long as people don't try to game the
system i mean we write actually a lot in
the book about
this system right so if you want to game
the system and if you're a democrat and
you want to get in more often or you
want to present a different viewpoint
you can just call the republican line
but um we try to catch them
it'd be very interesting for us to
actually look at the numbers there and
see what kind of cheating what kind of
level cheating there is because that's
what we try to do is use the tools of
economics and data to see in what ways
are people being honest and charitable
and on the other hand you know dishonest
and cheating and stealing in answer to
your second question
we don't really write a lot about what
most people think of as the economy or
especially macroeconomics in terms of uh
the the the gap between black and white
achievement and uh education and income
in this country well it's a huge and
hugely important question which we kind
of nibble around the edges at in our
book but i will tell you there's a
fellow who we do write about in
freakonomics his name is roland fryer
f-r-y-e-r and he's a young economist at
harvard he's 28 years old a young
african-american economist and we write
about him a little bit in this book i'm
actually working on a book about him
that'll take probably a few years what's
remarkable about roland fryer is his
background was a very difficult one in
which it really encompasses a lot of
what we think of as a as a modern
african-american experience meaning a
lot of very good things a lot of very
difficult things from a familial
perspective to a educational perspective
what roland is doing at harvard now is
he is turning his attention very much
like the book the covenant with black
america is attempting to do he's turning
his attention to what he calls the uh
the the the situation of black
underachievement in this country in
other words
he's looking very precisely at the
numbers in the ways in which african
americans are lagging behind whites and
some other groups in education in health
outcomes and income outcomes and a
variety of things because he's an
economist he's not approaching this with
a political agenda and frankly because
he is black himself he's able to deal
with issues that others might not be
able to so he has been studying a lot of
things having to do with the acting
white phenomenon for instance where
black children are often thought to
be held back or hold themselves back
because they don't want to be subject to
ridicule by their black peers for
achieving too well in school a
phenomenon that would be seen as acting
white instead of just theorizing about
it or opining about it he uses data and
he tries to look at the effect of that
how it happens and if so what can be
done to ameliorate it so
the best answer i have to your very good
and very difficult question frankly is
keep an eye on roland fryer jr and there
are others like him who again i think
we're getting to a point in history
which i think is encouraging that
people are using data to look at these
very difficult problems and when you use
data and you're alleging to what the
data have to say then your politics and
your opinion and your emotions are often
removed from it and i find that that's
often the most fruitful way to solve a
problem we're at book expo america it's
taking place this year in washington d.c
and we are talking with stephen dubner
who is one of the authors of
freakonomics as we take our next call
we'll show you a little bit of what the
the floor of the
expo looks like as booksellers and
librarians across the country are
looking at the possibilities of buying
some fall books from publishers niagara
falls you're next hello hello i'm glad
to be on the line by the way i did obey
the rules i did call the republican line
though i am left leaning on most issues
so there you go my question actually is
a good follow-up to the last question it
was regarding naming children and naming
conventions i work in an inner city
charter school in buffalo new york and
many of the names of the children that i
teach are made up by the mother
they are
some of them are pretty um you what
you'd expect shaquan and chiquela but
some of them really flout these
hooked on phonics i guess conventions
with the different arianas ariana
spelled r e
o n a r e anna and so i was wondering
about the earning potential
of children whose names are made up that
really kind of flout the pronunciation
conventions obviously that has to have
some effect as opposed to you know you
would you would think so wouldn't you uh
we actually have a chapter an entire
chapter in the book which probably a lot
of people argue is way too much on uh on
baby names on on what a name actually
what kind of significance a name
actually has what what a name is meant
to be so let me take a step back for a
minute before i answer your question
particularly
if you think about what a name is it's
an odd thing really you know i'm a
parent so i and my wife when we have a
child we decide on the name we're going
to give the kid and that kid is then
going to go through his or her entire
life with this name that we gave it
before we knew anything about this kid
it's kind of odd if you think about it
in other words it would sort of make
more sense if people got to pick their
own names at a certain point in their
life so i'm not i'm not very politically
involved if i were i might argue for a
national naming age you know at age 14
or 16 or 18 everybody gets to look at
their name brittany and i say i don't
want to be britney i want to be
cassandra whatever right i don't i don't
think there's a lot of you know a lot of
upside in me pushing that movement but
that's kind of the thinking so what what
is a name a name is really in economic
terms it's a parent's
it's the parents signaling device
they're signaling to the world and when
i say the world i mean
to their friends their community their
co-workers their family whatever what
they expect of this child do they expect
it to be a traditional child they expect
it to be a successful child do they
expect it to stay within the very tight
culture they may live in or out in the
world or so on and so what we look at is
what kind of effect a name will actually
have on a child and there have been
studies over the years that show that
suggested that if you have a distinctly
let's say african-american name in the
united states or a distinctively
immigrant sounding name in britain let's
say that that name itself is a huge
handicap to your life outcome
and this research was suggested by some
things called audit studies where you
send out identical resumes with two
different names you know jane smith and
shaquilla smith okay
my co-author on freakonomics steve
levitt along with roland fryer the
economist i mentioned a moment ago um
did a lot of work using a big big big
pile of data names database from
california including i think 40 million
names and they found that if you
actually track the life outcome of
people who have a distinctly
african-american name versus an
equivalent person meaning someone from
the same kind of background same kind of
parents with a mainstream american white
sounding name there's no difference in
the life outcome in other words it's not
the name that has an effect on your life
now that's not to say that someone named
shakila won't have a worse outcome in
life than someone named jane you know
what she will but that's because someone
with the name of shaquilla is more
likely to have been named by someone
with a low income low education set of
parents in other words it's an indicator
of what kind of household they come from
but it doesn't um it doesn't actually
cause anything and that a lot of what we
argue in free economics is to try to
distinguish between indicators and
causes or more more better put between
correlation and cause a lot of times two
things move together and people assume
that one causes the other whereas in
fact they don't ohio is next paynesville
ohio you're on stephen devnet
uh yeah i read the book i thought it was
pretty good
and
i kind of had the same thought on myself
i remember when uh
the
55 mile an hour speed limits came in the
idea was to save gas and when they
wanted to bring it back uh
it was to save lives so it was something
different
which is why i figured maybe the aids
crisis might be a great cure for poverty
everybody would uh why the aids crisis
for poverty you said okay
i'm sorry was i missed the question i'm
sorry no i i i i'm getting to
everybody would be scared of getting
aids they'd all practice safe sex and
use condoms and they wouldn't have all
these illegitimate children and
that would help to make things better
that didn't happen partially because a
gay men were the ones that wearing
cottons but why do you think
that didn't happen and uh have there
been any
unforeseen side effects of aids
you know that's a good question i think
there is research on the kind of
overarching societal effects of aids and
i i'm just not familiar with it enough
to speak about the the one piece of the
research i do know that we did write
about in our new york times column was
actually a really interesting question
um it asked whether aids had an effect
on um
sexual preference in other words
and what the data say is that it did in
other words what happened is um there
were gay men during the the height of
the aids uh crisis or aids scare or
however you want to look at it
who became who began having less sex
with men and more sex with women okay
there were
heterosexual women
who began having less sex with men and
more sex with women in other words
there's data to suggest that what aids
did the fear of aids did is it made men
on the margin at least not in great mass
but on the margin made men less likely
to be homosexual and women more likely
to be homosexual all right well it's
also really interesting about this
research this was done by a graduate
student at the university of chicago
named andrew francis
it showed that
not only did
he looked at people who had a relative
or yeah it was a family member who died
of aids and among those people he saw
that gay people who had a family member
who died of aids not only did they
switch their sexual behavior often but
in surveys they would switch their
sexual declarations about themselves
their sexual identity in other words
they would be more likely to answer that
they're not attracted to members of the
same sex and so on so this was our very
narrow effort to try to address a
question that's on the mind of a lot of
people which is what is homeless what is
sexuality in general is it an innate
preference or is it a learned
environmental um choice and it's a
really interesting uh problem to try to
address or an issue to try to address
and again economics would seem to be an
unlikely set of tools to use it but it
kind of works last call for our guest
edgewater new jersey hi
hello mr dubner i enjoy your writing
very much thank you
i'd like to ask you uh
it seems
tell me correct me if i'm wrong but as
far as i know roughly five for at least
in america five percent of the country
has 90 percent of the wealth or controls
90 of the wealth i think it's somewhere
in that neighborhood again correct me if
i'm wrong i don't know the number but
we'll proceed as if that's so all right
the question i'd like to ask has any
economist that you know of or has anyone
done the study uh
let's say
let's say just for the sake of argument
roughly everybody was paid the same
maybe three tiers you know doctors would
maybe get 80 000 um regular people would
get 60 000 and maybe down to 40 000.
that was the low end
could is if that wealth was spread out
what i'm asking is what kind of middle
class life could everybody live as
opposed to people uh being terrified
that they're going to lose their health
care and and having all these living in
this land of many malls
i grew up loving america i hate america
now aside from the big cities it's all
it's all the same burger kings and the
same stores and every place in the
country looks exactly the same it's it's
horrible
well um let let me begin by saying since
i'm not an economist i'm not gonna wax
uh econometrically about macroeconomics
what i will say is this um
what economists generally feel is that
markets work and the reason markets work
is because we people are self-interested
okay so adam smith hundreds of years ago
made a very powerful argument he said
when left to their own devices people
will compete for goods and services so
what we write about in freakonomics is
really we talk about economics is really
the study of incentives which is to say
the study of how people get what they
want or need especially when other
people want or need the same thing now
that may not sound a lot like what we
think of as the economy but i would
argue that it actually is what adam
smith declared was that you know when
people are self-interested when they
compete markets are very efficient and
there is what he called an invisible
hand that seems to shape society in a
way that as it turns out is pretty
benign is often you know when when there
is a need for help in some quarter if
left to its own devices a free market
will essentially create that help and
when people are competing for goods and
services a lot of good things happen
that's the argument again that most
economists would make a lot of other
people would make exactly the argument
or the plea that you're making which is
i hate this disparity it seems unfair it
seems cruel it seems wrong it seems
un-american what we do know if we were
having this conversation 50 years ago
i it might be a harder answer right now
i think we can have an answer to your
question
how do planned economies work the answer
is not very well
the soviet union had a very very
well-planned economy top to bottom i
never spent a lot of time in the soviet
union i know and have worked with a lot
of people who have my my wife is one of
them
and what you see is when the market does
not exist for people to compete for
things that they want
when
a central planned uh economy is
responsible for dictating the quality of
life of everyone
you have a great deal more corruption
you have less equity you have less
egalitarian approaches to uh lifestyle
to outcomes and so on and so what i
would argue is
it's a little bit like what you say when
you're you're in a place with stormy
weather if you don't like the shape of
this country with the burger kings or
the malls or whatever it is stick around
10 years and it's going to change
markets move fast markets move
efficiently and so i know that's not a
very satisfying answer but i think that
we often attribute evils to uh uh
planning or uh uh uh things that don't
exist and and really
i would argue that this economy in this
country politically and
and the capitalism are actually
producing an awful lot of good for an
awful lot of people and for those who
aren't doing as well yet the opportunity
exists
stephen dubner should people buy now or
wait for the fall your book it's up to
them their preference this is what it
looks like freakonomics a rogue
economist explores the hidden side of
everything mr devner wrote this along
with steven levitt thanks very much
thank you very much today and book tv is
here we are been live all day at book
expo which is the annual uh book trade
show it's the largest book trade show in
the country and we have this year it's
in washington dc at the washington
convention center well besides the floor
and the kinds of things that we've been
showing you today there are many panel
discussions and speeches that happen
throughout the four days and three or
four days of book expo the kickoff
speech for this year was tim russert and
tim russert was talking about his brand
new book wisdom of our fathers lessons
and letters from daughters and sons next
we're going to show you in its entirety
mr russert's speech from thursday night
uh we have an amazing keynote speaker
tonight